bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute
quest'anno video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
la prima puntata di cazzeggio time non
vedevo l'ora di iniziarlo ragazzi allora
vi spiego un attimino di cosa si tratta
perché se no è una nuova serie che
voglio iniziare che completamente random
nel senso che commento cose che trovo e
che vedo e che sento e che respiro
faccio cose che non rientrano nel
gameplay come al solito una cosa che
volevo fare un casino di tempo e come
primo episodio ragazzi ha deciso di
farvi vedere una chicca una super chicca
è quindi ragazzi se sente però dire che
possiamo partire con pubblicità
giapponesi io non so cosa sto per andare
incontro quindi c'è
cos'è sta roba pubblicità sul top credo
a non porterà a me non lo so che caffè
era amen
c'è una tipa stanno facendo assaggiare
ma come sei bella gnocca saggia il miur
a me cosa cazzo appena visto fossero
così le pubblicità italia ne guarderei
la televisione solo per questo è una
roba strana o mio dio
oh mio dio cos'era quella roba cos'è
questa storia d'amore fantasy ma cosa
cazzo o merda ma veramente perché fa per
te no no ascoltati o no kat
la cosa che non si può vedere che cosa
strana e canzoncine può essere galan vi
prego cosa fa oh mio dio agli alieni
averci mancava quello calde
era la pubblicità di di patatine di
patatine
noi abbiamo rocco non ci annuncia ne
sono due cose diverse
sentite un attivo di oh oh mio dio cosa
tutto questo ha detto che non voglio
saperlo ma questa mattina sempre
comunque una storia d'amore migliore di
twilight io sto cercando di capire che
cosa sto guardando grazie al mare a me
più o meno mi rispecchia quando mangio
le patatine la stessa cosa è la madonna
è la fanta quella no vabbè che succeda
cosa ma povero cristiano un'amica ma
dargli un po di spazio con sta godendo
sta godendo con la coda ecco perché non
bisogna mai portare le donne a far la
spesa è un dato di fatto
cosa sta facendo questa sembro io quando
mia madre mi dice guarda ti la merenda a
scuola perché c'è un usb nel culo perché
era anche un accendisigari cioè una roba
del tipo vuoi mettere la chiavetta e
fumare e se vedi la chiavetta che si
muove perché hai fumato troppo la voglio
subito la gara o mio dio questo guadagni
porno perché stanno leccando delle
tazzine perché questo si sta ingrossando
l'asfalto cos'era cos'era cos'era
ragazzi cos'era chi è perché c'è
superman
quello non è superman
questo mi piace bene per non poter
metterla subito a ali sta lanciando
della il rifiuto mi son o misto
rifiutando di vedere questa un buca che
rilascia è bellissimo ma come ma cos'ha
fatto le hanno pagate queste per far
star super fatto spot quanto cioè una
come dio ragazzi di essa in confronto
non era un cazzo e lui il nuovo zhang
ramstein
e incredibile ma dalla prossima ragazzi
che mi se ecco questa mi sembra piano ma
che non tirino nel latte addosso ti
prego che sta facendo ma si sta
spogliando perfetta da una roba tipo di
un profumo io ho paura
certo ovvio in assenso non sa se questa
è svenuta a carta moneta è diventata un
asino in europa i 1100 mio dio napoli
[Musica]
sono veramente italiani ma noi ce la
pubblicità italiana in giappone
non ci posso credere cioè si sgonfia è
una roba non abbiamo capito un cazzo la
vita alle ragazze piace il naso da
pagliaccio c'è domani tutti così cazzo
no vabbè run dei dolci ma perché mi
sembra normale ma neanche wars the force
è la stessa cosa ragazzi non è possibile
super pizza
cos'è sta roba è la coca cola sta
bevendo della coca cola ma c'è bisogno
di fare tutto sto casino se ho paura di
bere là delle lattine ragazzina robben
da 100 cosa fa questa cosa sta
succedendo
ti prego ma no ma come chicca lande
l'angelo regali lui e l'angelo della
vita cosa fa madonna neanche ten simile
di specie di station
io vado in giappone ragazzi ve lo dico
solo per vedere le pubblicità è assurdo
perché cazzo perché ancora il top del
rame e ancora cosa cazzo perché quando
mangiano ramen devono ballare ma che
cazzo di problemi avverte che la
pubblicità del durc arching serio
veramente era chiusa
che cosa sexy adocchiato l'hamburger
ragazzo incredibile si è spiaccicato a
terra non si sa come striscia come cosa
fai
cosa fa se fissa un serpente cosa vuoi
che la stampa c'è ragazzi è arrivato
alla fredda è arrivata la preda e adesso
se la mala no no no no no no non lo fare
non lo fare
mastica mastica le cose che muori porca
[ __ ] e va beh ragazzi come come ha
fatto come cazzo fatto io voglio farlo
bene la mcdonald e fare una cosa già
vede calzoni libro poi muoio perché non
toglierò mai questa ha vinto tutto tutto
dai ragazzi non ne ha ancora abbastanza
ecco forse ho parlato troppo presto
il cane che messaggio ovvio c'è la
whatsapp è il cane più figo della storia
nel caso chiuso c'è un state mangiando
sì cosa sono
cosa sta cosa è successo al partito il
concerto dei metallica e tali che
giapponesi però che fanno solo così è
questa rimasta leggermente incastrata
lega anche lui sani mastica come hanno
fatto a finire là dentro come cazzo
avete fatto a finirla dentro nello stile
avete voglia di spiegarmelo non so cosa
fanno sta nuotando la fai come hai fatto
a finirla dentro una edizione c'è un
gatto che uscì a è un gatto ragazzi e
l'invasione dei gatti giganti anche a
parigi anche in italia anche a pisa e ha
raddrizzato la torre è meglio di niente
sentite non è infatti guarda amica mia
michael jackson sarebbe fiero di te
credimi questo è successo a per questi
sono quelli che fanno fuori le zanzare
quando attivi lo spray
certo allora compatto subito a comprare
un cazzo di spray vogliamo dei
giapponesi che ballo anche col gillet se
ti fai la barbati radon e giapponesi
pensa mi sembrava ariana grande da
lontano cosa è successo e cosa sta
facendo si sta mangiando un gelato
perfetto se abbiamo capito che segnò
anche ti mangi gelati col cazzo
ho capito che segnò aic sputi anche i
semi del melone grazie tesoro spiegami
come ti è venuta in mente questa niente
lei sputa i semi l'istituto temi dolce
voglio assolutamente farlo anch'io
subito disarmi star bonus esso stesso in
ogni caso l'attacco del gigante ma
salgono i giganti in uno spot ma è
uscito uno sulle bacheche ma era
veramente l'attacco i giganti ma io
l'avrei fatta diversamente più o meno
più o meno così l'attacco di pasquale
pratico accordo ragazzini che posso
concludere qui tele pubblicità
giapponesi spero che vi siano piaciute
perché è una cosa che volevo fare un
casino di tempo la venerata cazzeggio
time non è solo questo e tante altre
cose
random c'è diversa dalle cose che faccio
di solito tipo questa adesso la reazione
ai video magari faccio cose tipo google
myself oa chi nator per dire niente
ragazzi questo primo episodio è andato
così volevo assolutamente farlo perché
voglio condividere con la magnificenza
delle pubblicità giapponesi che mio
addio quindi ragazzi spero che tutti
quanti andremo in giappone insieme a
vedere le pubblicità insieme come se tu
sei video è piaciuta da sotto momento mi
piace anche a porzioni facebook e come
video trapana d'estizione susseguirsi di
sfilate il civ il diavolo prossimo video
vedo ragazzi